this is when bengi has to step up to
save SKT on blue side remember with
bengi in they do not have an Italy
player you cannot give me not in Italy
we talked about how you need adaptation
and now you're forced to ban Nidalee on
blue side this could be the last game of
the night or Peggy has anything to say
we go to a game five already a two-time
world champion
bengi was supposedly over the hill but
bengi was a world champion and with
everything on the line SKT needed a win
a veteran voice to show them the path to
victory they needed banky after all
they've never won worlds without him
this is banky story say bengi song one
was born on November 21st 1994 and not
much is known about his life before
League of Legends bangies first recorded
games were on an amateur team called BB
team which played in a Korean secondary
league known as NL he on that team he
played alongside a legendary support
player toe-mah-toe
[Applause]
after the team disbanded bengi ended up
at a tryout for SK Telecom's a new
sister team sk telecom t1 k and though
he left mid away because he felt he
wasn't good enough to make the team
coach Kamath coma Joong Geun saw
something great in the young time and
managed to pull him back SKT was built
around a young solo Q star that was
turning heads at the time leaf faker son
kill meadow faker may be a trouble
you're dead Bart tries to clean it up
for real oh look at the class look in
the bows thank you why was bad the team
was designed to be aggressive
capitalizing on fakers play style it
would go something her and he gets out
clean SKT sister team placed third in
champions spring and posted impressive
results in their debut season but more
importantly they had the potential to be
great
[Applause]
ji won the team went 12 and 4 in the
summer season and qualified for Worlds
2013 were they swept royal club in the
grand finals to take home their
[Music]
[Applause]
SKT returned home to Korea as champions
and they didn't slow down for even a
second but that is it
they're turning under the Nexus and SK
Telecom has done the impossible
there is a perfect season for SK Telecom
t1 K just an exceptional performance and
these guys continue just to wall SKT t1
champions winter with a perfect record
and were without a doubt the best team
in the world
Sweden Syria so SK Telecom cotton okay
wait even a bell to Tennessee repair 11
dil KO mu Rosamund oyako charger and a
panda cubs Khadija good any given but
amidst all the success you notice
bangies play style slowly shifting his
early game aggression a hallmark of sk
teased fast-paced bulldozer play style
gave Wade is something more supportive
eat ownership started SK Telecom to an
urn how's old paycock ridiculous I
carried all ghetto kid any moving
software at all impact to Peggy new
potential form and owner she might stop
potentially Quran would add to student
bengi was fakers invisible Guardian he
was the man who set up faker for the
flashy plays that have made him a
legendary there's no question that faker
was the best but he couldn't have done
it without bengi after champions winter
SKT started to crumble
they placed fourth in champions spring
and were then swept in a tiebreaker
match against Samsung white which forced
him to play in the regional finals where
they would eventually lose to nausea and
white shield three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just a few months prior SKT were the
reigning world champions with a perfect
record in their home region but they
couldn't keep up
bengi wasn't solely blamed for the team
struggles with a common perception was
that Vayner the greatest player on earth
just couldn't carry his entire team hey
Conan who know you turn ships hand on a
superior as me and I'm a faker cetera
UST morado Timmy were generally Buteyko
cargo symmetry cement of a corner
European city no policy
SKT rebuilt in the offseason shedding
everyone except for Baker and bengi the
God and his right-hand man but even so
people were ready to write off bengi he
was part of a roster that not even faker
could carry and his mechanics were seen
as being out of date younger players
were faster more adaptable and had
deeper champion pools bringing that solo
queue to deer in 2015 SKT signed in Tom
jae-hyung as a substitute for Ben key
and swap between the two junglers
throughout the season what was telling
though was the fact that SKT elected to
play Tom for all three games of their
final series against the GE Tigers a
series SKT went on to win three
under the support a double Cobra Myron
no it will end
snap getting low wolf still up and there
it is the first Nexus turret down the
second exit straight down a triple kill
for Noren and SKT with todd with
easyhoon takes the three o gg we'll see
you at the invitational in interviews
bengi said that watching Tom play helped
him regain his confidence after his
abysmal 2014 season that's right banging
the guy who walked out of tryouts only
to be pulled back in needed a rookie to
remind himself how good he did
[Music]
as Katie went on to win the summer
season punching their tickets to world
in the process
fortunately for bengi SKT took midlane
substitute we easyhoon Ji Hoon to the
tournament
meaning that bengi was the only jungler
that he would feel the world's SKT went
on to win the tournament giving faker
and banging their second World
Championship in SKT will be your first
ever two-time world champions
but even with a second World
Championship under his belt people still
kept harping on bengi here's a fun time
bengi has never played in Italy in his
entire career ever never ever he cannot
play ahead of the spring 2016 season SKT
signed Kang blank
Sangu and started him for most of the
regular season
bengi only played in 17 of SK T's 41
games in the spring and rode the bench
throughout the playoffs just wish I
could have been watching this scrim is
watching them decide between Bank and
Bank blank and bengi because from what
we send the video we've sent both of
them have been pretty pause sk t started
bengi more often in the summer but as
the season wore on
bengi lost more and more and was benched
after just 14 games again blank played
in the playoffs
instead of bengi blank were the one
thing you can say about him has stepped
up when he's needed to you think back to
lck final you think back to msi final he
was good in those series and he's gonna
need to be good today SKT took bengi
with them to Worlds in 2016 but he only
played in two games during the group
stage SKT started banging against royal
in the quarterfinals but after losing
Game one quickly subbed him out for
blank
I like the substitution for them I think
Blanc has been their go-to for the
majority of the season and I was
surprised whenever we would see bengi if
they weren't gonna make it a permanent
thing maybe they thought it was because
of his World Championship experience but
this SKT team has won the IM world
championship with blank they want msi
with playing and I think if they want to
win they should be doing it with blank
the writing seemed to be on the wall for
bengi he was still good but no longer
great
but in Game four of the semi-finals SKT
were on the ropes as kids you have to
change things up in this next one
because they tried round two of the
misfortune lane they lost again they
have to change and with everything on
the line
SK team needed a win that's when they
called in Bank their gopher girl double
bomb on this
goes banking so far so good for the
first pick middle e the fact that they
your kid revived means nothing to be had
on what a great so Diaz by step getting
away from it all bombs are gonna land
either with a solo at the time and as
gates here breaking this one apart now
and now it could be dangerous Wolf's
gonna die to cover more shots anyway
the black of Kurla started to think
about a matter if you already had the
opium and baggy again the double kill
look at the trade damage rain running
through to your life but he will in fact
get away with it and this could be the
game would he play right now curls got
nothing left to do sure you pop the
guardian angel but what does it even
matter its a-440 it's the ACE
it's the game SK Telecom t1 bringing us
to Game five
what a series we hear I can't wait for
the fifth game SKT fight their way back
in elimination game
subs back and he saves SKT now we're
going to Game five there is rush there
it is it's peanut a lot of damage down
300 HP on bail the chase
2,700
cannot pick up bang and it's a-440
Peggy getting the kill again as they
move on to the next
and it's all
t1
in cell 3 Oh against Fox Tigers in the
series and
[Applause]
bengi started in form of SKT strand
final games against Samsung Galaxy going
3 to 1 and notching his and fakers third
world championship in five years
cementing s Katie's legacy as League of
Legends first dynasty surely the entire
world would finally see that when bengi
is sitting next to faker no team in the
world could stop them but bengi is
always doomed to be the bridesmaid and
never the bride he's invisible and most
importantly he's not faker
the London hotel has their dinner and
I'm willing to give up something there
she murders that they don't understand a
single mom or contagion ghost amoeba SKT
dropped banging in 2017 and replaced him
with the Tigers star jungler hon Tina
Wang hope
bengi went off to vici gaming in China
where he ended up losing a relegation
match and being dropped from that team
to snake destroy the Nexus and take the
win 3 to 0 over vici gaming as Kiki had
a strong 2017 placing first in the
spring playoffs and second
but they didn't look dominant going to
do the upset is completed the girls go
through the asking
Samsung Galaxy their 2017 world
champions
SKT placed second our worlds in 2017
which marked their first ever loss in a
world grand final series their first
time playing at the tournament without
bengi you know it's it's insane what
they did knowing that they've won three
World Championships expecting to twin
four is sure as natural because of the
dominant streak they've had but in all
seriousness what they've accomplished no
one's gonna come close to this or show
something as quite close with the two
two victories but in theory it's still
incredible that it maybe takes one year
maybe takes two years for them to come
back to that same form but they still
have they like common knows the recipe
to success
SKT knows the recipe for success within
league it's impossible to say exactly
how much bang impacted escapees play
style and whether or not he completely
altered the way SKT treats junglers
moving forward but he's returned to SKT
this time as a coach bengi and faker
have been reunited while bengi is
playing in even more supportive and
visible role this time around one thing
will always remain true when the
unkillable demon king has bengi by his
side nothing can stop SKT
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button